[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
NICOLAS COLIN:
Thank you very much.
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you all for
attending the talk,
and thank you for
everyone watching online.
I'm really glad to
be here to share
a few ideas about
technology, policy,
and how we need to upgrade our
institutions in these times
of radical change.
To start discussing
that, I'd like
you to picture a runner,
one of those runners here.
So it's not a runner that's
running a five kilometer
race or a sprint
or even a marathon.
It's a runner that's into what
is known as ultra running.
That is a very long
race that drags
through the day and the night.
And anyone here run
that kind of race?
Oh, you do, so you're
in better shape than me,
and you can relate to
what I have in mind.
So the idea here is that
to run that kind of race,
ultra running, you need more
than being in great shape.
Well, you need a compass.
You need a map.
You need a headlamp to help
you see through the night.
And the reason I'm
mentioning this today
is because I think we together,
as a society, are currently
involved in that kind of race.
And it's a race
that is very much
about economic development.
It's a long race,
because it's a race that
can be seen as being
divided into two parts.
So the first part of
this ultra running
towards economic development
in the digital economy
is about building
great tech companies.
And you here in
the Bay Area have
been very good at doing that.
But there's a second
part of that race, which
is about inventing
or discovering
the institutions that will
make the new economy more
sustainable and more inclusive.
And that's a discussion or
conversation we in Europe--
because I'm European, you can
hear that from my accent--
we in Europe are very keen to
have that kind of conversation
about new institutions
for the digital economy.
And if we want to win, if we
want our Western countries
to remain the most advanced
economies in the world.
The most sustainable
economies in the world
and the most inclusive
economies in the world,
we really need to be ready to
run that very long race that's
divided into two parts.
So as for me, I'm the
co-founder and director
of a firm called TheFamily.
So we are based in Europe.
We have offices in London,
where I live, in Paris
where we founded the
firm six years ago,
and in Berlin, in Germany,
and in Brussels as well.
And what we're
doing in Europe is
supporting ambitious
entrepreneurs
across Europe,
entrepreneurs who want
to build large pan
European tech companies.
But before doing that,
I have a background
in policy and
government, because I
used to be trained in
the French civil service.
I actually worked for
more than five years
for the French government
before joining the tech world.
And so I have this
mixed background
that makes me interested in
both parts of the race, the part
that is about building
tech companies
and the other part that
is about discovering
new institutions to make our
economy more developed, more
sustainable, and more inclusive.
And I've written this
book, "Hedge," which was
published last year to share--
well, to try and invite
everyone in the tech world
to participate in
that race that we
have to run if we want
our economies to be
more balanced and more
stable and more rewarding
for the many as
opposed to the few.
And so I'd like to share a few
ideas about what's in the book
today.
So first of all,
it's a book that I
wrote to address an
American audience.
It relies on what
I used to study
in the past about American
history, American politics.
So I've tried to use
all that knowledge
of this great country,
the US, to try and address
that audience that
is so different
from a European audience
in terms of interests,
in terms of perspectives,
experiences, and so on.
And that's because
I think the US has
a critical, unique
contribution to make
to winning that two-part race.
And there are three
reasons for that.
So the first reason
is that the US
has a large, successful,
thriving, local tech industry.
And it's a very important
part of discovering
new institutions, because
if you have a government,
like we have in Europe, that
tries to invent and to design
new institutions without having
large tech companies that
are local and domestic,
and that they can rely on
for insight, for knowledge,
for direction, for making sure
that the new institutions are
really in line with how we
create value in the new economy,
how we produce, how we consume,
how we work, well, the
institutions that will come out
of this effort will be ill
designed and not aligned
with what the new
economy is about.
So because the US has a thriving
tech industry, part of it
is located here in the Bay
Area, it's really well ahead
in terms of being able to
design new institutions.
And that's the first reason why
we really need, as the world,
the US to participate in that.
The second reason why the US is
so interesting in that regard
is that there is a
federal system here.
And when you talk about
government designing
new institutions, it's not only
about the federal government
in Washington DC.
It's also about the 50
states and the large cities
that all have the legal
and financial power
to make experiments
in terms of policy
to try and tackle the
problems in an innovative way
and to eventually discover
the new institutions that
then can be scaled up
at the federal level.
So this is a picture
of Louis Brandeis.
So he was the
first Jewish person
to be appointed to
the US Supreme Court
early in the 20th century.
And I I'm using
his picture here,
because he's the one who coined
this very interesting concept
of the 50 states or
the American states
as laboratories of democracy.
And that's because he was a keen
believer in the federal system
and was very interested
in the capacity
to experiment with new
policies on the ground,
at the state level,
or at the local level,
and then get
inspiration from that
to scale up new policies
and new institutions.
And so the US has that.
You have a domestic
thriving tech industry.
You have a federal
system that provides room
for many experiments in policy.
And third, well, you already
did that the previous time
when we went through
radical change economically,
politically, in
terms of technology,
as well at the beginning
of the 20th century.
Well, the US was a
pioneer at the time
in terms of reacting
to that change
by designing new institutions
to try and balance
that new economy that
nobody really understood.
And so it's what I call
the Great Safety Net 1.0.
It was first designed
here in the US,
and then it provided
inspiration for other countries
in the world.
And it is known by historians
as the Second New Deal.
So this is actually a picture
of President Roosevelt signing
an act known as the
Social Security Act.
Behind him is
Frances Perkins, who
is the Secretary of Labor
at the time, the first woman
to be appointed to cabinet.
And the Second New Deal was--
well, many different policies
and many different decisions
that together formed
the new social contract,
which enabled the US
to succeed economically
and politically in the
decades after that.
And so there were social
security, obviously.
There was government support
for banks issuing mortgages
with Fannie Mae and
later Freddie Mac.
There was upgraded
banking regulations.
There was assistance
from the government
to unions so that unions
could bargain with employers.
And all that together formed
what I call the Great Safety
Net 1.0.
And so what about that
Great Safety Net 1.0?
So I'd like to share two
ideas about that today.
First, it used to be incredible.
It worked extremely
well in terms
of providing support to
everyone, households,
businesses, and making it
possible for the economy
to thrive.
But second, today it's
obsolete, because the economy
has recently gone
through radical change.
It's not the same that it was at
the time of the Second New Deal
obviously.
And so we need to be ready to
upgrade that Great Safety Net
and go from 1.0 to 2.0.
But before that or
before discussing that,
I'd like to share a few ideas
about what was the Great Safety
Net 1.0.
So the first thing that
you should have in mind
here is that it was designed
around the large corporations
of the time, the '40s
corporations that were mostly
about mass production
of tangible goods
in large factories,
assembly lines.
And so the Great Safety
Net was designed--
it was very much focused
on the people working
in those corporations,
mainly factory workers,
working along assembly lines.
And because the new safety net
lifted those workers up, it--
through those, because they
were the most critical part
of the workforce at
the time, working
for the most productive
corporations of the time,
they lifted everyone
up or almost everyone,
at least the
majority of workers.
And so the Great
Safety Net, designed
for those people,
those factory workers,
relied on three pillars.
That's the model have been
developing in the book.
So the first pillar was
about covering those people
against critical risks.
And it was all--
it relied on a concept
known by policy wonks
as social insurance.
So social insurance again
was about providing coverage
against critical risk.
So for instance, if you
were too old to work,
because you didn't have the
stamina and strength anymore
to be able to work along
assembly lines, very
physical demanding
work, then the state
would provide you
with a pension.
Or you were sick, or you
were hurt at the factory,
then the insurance regime
would provide you with money
to pay the rent and
access to affordable care,
so that you can get back in
shape and get back to work.
Or if you lost your
job, they'll provide you
with unemployment benefits,
so that, again, you
can pay the rent until--
and maybe learn new skills
before you find a new job.
So that was all
social insurance,
and what it performed
was covering
people against critical risks.
The second pillar was
the financial system.
And the financial system is
part of the Great Safety Net,
because it provides people
with access to capital
whenever they need it.
And so why did you
need access to capital
in the '40s, the economy
in the 20th century?
You needed access
to capital when
you wanted to buy your house,
and a house, especially here
in the US was an
extremely critical part
of economic security
for households.
But no one could buy
a house paying cash.
You needed to borrow money from
a bank, issuing a mortgage.
And those mortgages were
operated by the private sector,
but they were made possible
by government-sponsored
institutions, such as
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac.
And so it's not because
it's to the private sector
that it's not part of
the Great Safety Net.
The Great Safety Net effectively
included a significant segment
of private business, delivering
economic security and support
to households.
You also needed
money to buy a car.
A car, in the past,
used to be critical,
because you needed
that car to go
from home to work, to
school, to shopping mall,
to baseball stadium.
Without a car, you couldn't
access all the opportunities
and you couldn't find a
job in the '40s economy.
So the financial system was here
to provide access to capital.
And the third pillar of
the Great Safety Net 1.0
was strong trade unions.
And they became strong following
the New Deal in the US,
because they were assisted
by the government which
provided them with the
strength and the credit
to be able to bargain
with employers.
And the reason why unions were
critical in that complex nexus
of institutions is because--
well, the version
of the Great Safety
Net that was designed right
after the New Deal in the 1930s
was designed for the
economy of the time.
But then the economy over
the course of decades
went through several
waves of radical change.
And each time you needed to
upgrade the social contract
to make the institutions work
for the economy of the day.
And so you needed someone
to take care of that,
to push in favor of upgrading
the institutions and the rules
and regulations,
and trade unions
were the one who
delivered results
at least until the 1970s.
And so that's what I call
the Great Safety Net 1.0.
It was designed some
time in the 1930s
to deliver good jobs, a steady
income, and economic security
to most workers in the
context of the '40s economy
or what economist Carlota Perez
calls the age of the automobile
and mass production.
And that worked incredibly
well for several decades.
But today, it's obsolete.
And to understand
why it's obsolete,
we need to revisit
the various pillars
and realize how the
economy has changed
and why the those legacy
institutions don't
deliver anymore.
So first, let's start
with social insurance.
So one main reason why social
insurance regimes are obsolete
today is because we
can't fund them anymore.
This is a picture that shows
you the projected evolution
of the US federal public debt.
And most of that growing
debt that you see here
is because of Social
Security and Medicare.
And the reason why we have
those funding problems
with social insurance is because
the tax system has not been
designed for today's economy.
It was designed to tax
households and business
in the '40s economy, organized
mostly around manufacturing.
But today, the economy
is not like that anymore.
And so we have a hard
time-- governments
have a hard time
generating fiscal revenue
to pay for covering
risks for the many.
That's one problem that we have
with social insurance today.
Another problem is that we don't
cover against today's risks.
There are risks that still
exist, like you can still
be too old to be able to work.
You can still get sick,
and then you need care.
But there are certain
risks that we're still
covering focusing on that are
not that critical anymore.
So I wanted to show you that
picture of Julius Yego, who's
also known as YouTube
Man, by the way,
because he learned to throw
the javelin by watching
videos of athletes on YouTube.
And he went on to become
an Olympic champion himself
a few years back.
It's an exceptional case and
not everyone is like him,
being able to learn from
watching videos on YouTube.
But what it suggests, I think,
is a very important idea.
It's that today in
the digital economy,
because we have
so many resources
online to learn new skills,
to discover new activities,
to spot interesting
opportunities, losing your job
and not having the right
skills is not as critical
a risk anymore.
And so governments
are very much focused
on that, like reskilling
the workforce,
developing the workforce.
But in fact, the workforce today
has access to many resources
that make it easier for
them to learn new skills
and to move on the labor market.
So it's a risk that
used to be critical,
but that is not
critical anymore today.
On the other hand,
there are risks
that weren't that critical
in the past that are
becoming more critical today.
And I think that
the next frontier
when it comes to covering
risks is the housing market.
So we're in San Francisco,
so you obviously
know that prices
go up constantly,
makes it difficult for
people to afford housing.
It makes it difficult for
people who are not here
to move here to seize the
many opportunities that
are provided by a vibrant
economy like the one in San
Francisco.
And this is typical
of a risk that
wasn't that critical
in the past,
because in the past, in an
economy dominated by factories,
most people lived in suburban
areas, and in suburban areas,
land is cheap.
So there wasn't that tension
on the housing market
that exists today,
because today,
most jobs, more and more jobs,
more and more opportunities
are located in large cities.
And that's why most workers
are flocking into those cities
and trying to afford
housing, and because we
don't build enough, and because
most regulations on the housing
market are obsolete,
because we didn't design
the right institutions
to make for a more
welcoming urban housing
market for workers.
Well, a lot of people
cannot afford housing,
where there are jobs and
opportunities for them.
So this is typical
of a risk that
wasn't that critical
in the past,
but it is becoming more
critical as the economy becomes
more urban, and that
calls for designing
a new kind of social
insurance to cover people
against the risks of not
being able to afford housing,
where there are jobs and
opportunities for them.
So that's for social insurance.
Now, let's move to
the financial system.
The financial system, the
legacy financial system
and the part that we're
interested in here
that is consumer finance
is obsolete as well,
because it provides
us with capital
to invest in assets that are
not that critical anymore.
So for instance, it
makes it quite easy--
the financial system
makes it easy to buy
a house in suburban areas.
But today, as I mentioned, most
jobs in the digital economy
are located in cities.
So you're not interested
in the mortgage
that makes it possible for you
to buy a house in suburbia.
You want to live in
the city, and no bank
will be able to lend you
the money to do that.
Another other thing that's
even less critical is the car.
So there are many cars here
parked near those houses.
And when you lived
in suburban areas,
it was critical to own a car.
But most people living in cities
today know that owning a car
is more a problem than a
solution in your everyday life,
because it costs a lot of money.
You don't know where to park it.
There's congestion on
the roads, et cetera.
So you prefer to rely on public
transit or ride hailing or car
sharing or other solutions,
and owning a car is not
that critical anymore.
But on the other
hand, there are things
that we'd like to invest in
today that the banking system
and consumer finance
don't provide capital for,
like switching jobs.
In our more
entrepreneurial economy,
we have to hop from job
to job far more often
than in the past.
But switching job is not
only like, I quit my job,
and I find another one.
In many cases, it's about
taking some time off
to reflect on what
I'd like to do, maybe
learning new skills on YouTube
or in learning communities,
and then maybe move
to another city.
But if you have a family, you
need to bring your spouse,
and your spouse needs to
find a new job as well.
And then you need
to bring your kids,
and your kids need to
move to a new school.
So all in all, it costs a
lot of money, switching jobs.
But if you go to a bank,
and you say to your banker,
I'd like to switch job, and I'd
like you to lend me some money
to cover the costs of doing
that, they won't lend you
the money, because we
never created something
equivalent to Fannie
Mae or Freddie Mac,
but to provide people with
capital to switch jobs.
And so that's typical of an
ill-designed financial system
when it comes to
today's economy.
The other reason why the
financial system is obsolete
today is because
it's overstretched.
So it all led us--
this is a woman
protesting Wall Street
right after the financial
crisis 10 years ago.
And the financial
crisis can very much
be read as the
result of relying too
much on the financial
system to provide people
with capital and
economic security
at the expense of
the other pillars.
So we've neglected
social insurance
by not funding it
and upgrading it.
We've neglected unions that
are being basically wiped out
of the map, and
we've relied too much
on only one pillar out of the
three, the financial system,
to provide economic
security to people.
And this is why the burden
became too heavy for the system
to support, and it all
collapsed in 2008, leading us
into the Great Recession.
Finally, while
unions are obsolete,
but for obvious reasons,
they're defending jobs
that mostly don't
exist anymore, or that
are the minority on
today's labor market.
Their preferred means
of action, like going
on strike, also obsolete,
considering what
the economy is about today.
Their strongholds are all
legacy exhausted industries,
as opposed to new industries
and thriving industries.
And so trade unions,
as they are today,
have a hard time staying
relevant for workers.
So all in all,
it's all obsolete.
But to understand how we
can upgrade that safety net
and move from Great Safety Net
1.0 to Great Safety Net 2.0,
so there is a lot
about that in the book.
I've been trying in the book to
explain what the new economy is
about, how do we create
value in the new economy,
how production,
consumption, work,
relationships between
individuals and organizations
have changed.
But because I
don't have the time
to share everything
that's in the book today,
I'd like to focus on one
framework that's in the book,
and this is the framework
of hunters and settlers.
And it's one very important way
in which our world has changed
through the paradigm shift
from the '40s economy
to today's digital economy.
So in the past, the economy
was dominated by settlers.
And the reason for that is that
at the center of the economy,
the most critical
part of the economy
was large, industrial
corporations.
And those corporations were
so strong and so resilient
and also very rigid as a result
of that, but that they could
basically survive over
the course of decades
without having to invent
themselves too much.
And so because they
provided the stability,
everyone wanted to work
for those corporations.
That's where you had the highest
wages, the more benefits,
the more economic security.
And because those
corporations were
about large factories or
large office buildings,
you could really
settle around them,
like I'm going to work
for this employer,
I'm going to buy a
house nearby, I'm
going to find a school for my
kids nearby, and that's it.
I'm settled.
My life is settled.
I'm going to have
that job for life
and have a career with
the same employer.
And at the margin
of the economy were
the hunters, the ones who were
moving constantly from one city
to another, from
one job to another,
from one industry to another.
And so most hunters were like
students trying new jobs,
while still attending
a university
or migrants, or were at the high
end of the hunting way of life
were the people taking planes,
moving from five star hotel
to five star hotel, because
they worked in consulting
or finance or other things.
But that's very much how
the economy was organized.
So at the center were
the large corporations.
Around them were the
settlers, and then
at the margin of the
economy were the hunters.
And the institutions
that we had at the time
were extremely
rewarding for settlers,
because that was the norm.
That was the
preferred way of life.
Today, the economy has
been turned upside down.
And so I won't go
into the details,
but I'm happy to discuss that
if we have time for questions.
But one key idea
that's in the book
is that the large
corporations have
been replaced as the
center of the economy
by networked individuals.
I think that the most important
player in today's economy
is not the large
companies anymore.
It's we individuals,
because we are more equipped
with powerful computing
devices, and we're all connected
together through networks.
And that provides us
with a lot of power
and the organizations that
dominate today's economy are
precisely the ones
that have realized
there is no more power
in networked individuals,
and that have been deploying
their operations, so
has to harness that power
vested in networked individuals.
But because networked
individuals--
well, there's not the stability
that existed with large '40s
corporations anymore.
It's a network, so
it's constantly moving,
displaced, fragmented,
reorganized.
And people connected
through those networks
are more impatient.
They want to be served
faster with better
services at a cheaper price.
And so to be able to
compete in that economy,
you need to be ready
to be entrepreneurial,
and that's the key thing
that's-- by the way,
that's the reason why I've
decided to call the new
economy, the
Entrepreneurial Age.
That's not because I think
we all become entrepreneurs
in that economy.
It's because I'm
convinced that we'll all
work for more
entrepreneurial firms,
firms that will
design themselves,
so as to be able to
constantly innovate, so as
to better serve that multitude
of connected individuals.
And so when the economy is
about connected individuals,
networked individuals,
suddenly the hunters, those
who are ready to hop from job
to job to seize opportunities,
to come up with new
ideas, to be more
entrepreneurial in
their working life,
are rewarded, because they're
the best able to interact
with that very
important group that
is now at the center
of our economy,
the networked individuals.
And so this is why the economy
is now turned upside down.
It's because at the center
are the networked individuals.
Then the most critical
part of the workforce
is now the hunters, people that
are moving from opportunity
to opportunity
that are flexible,
that are able to rebound in an
economy that's more unstable,
because it's more
entrepreneurial.
And so the settlers, those who
really want it to stay in place
and to keep the same job and
to live in the same house,
are now at the margin,
suffering, because they're not
able to seize those
opportunities provided
by this more
entrepreneurial economy.
So that's the framework
I've been using.
And I think it's important
to have that in mind,
because it helps us realize how
we should revisit and reinvent
the various pillars
of the safety net.
And so as you go
back through those,
realizing that at the
center of the economy
it's not factory
workers anymore,
but it's networked
individuals, you
need to revisit every
pillar and to realize
that they should be
redesigned to better serve
the needs of hunters in an
economy driven by computing
and networks.
So what about social insurance?
Well, social insurance
should cover us
against the risks
that are associated
with the hunting way of life.
And I think, again, that
housing, urban housing
is the new frontier here.
We really need new
institutions to make
it possible for people
hunting from job to job
to afford housing
where there are jobs
and opportunities for them.
The financial system should
provide us with capital
to become better hunters.
Today it provides us with
capital to buy a house
or to buy your car, which
is not about hunting at all.
It should provide
us with capital
for whenever we want to
switch job, to switch careers,
or to move from one
city to another, capital
to take time off,
to learn new skills,
to move your entire family
from one city to another.
And this means that we
should invent something
like Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac, but to provide capital
for hunters, rather
than settlers.
And finally the
trade unions, well,
imagine if the trade
unions, instead
of defending workers,
where they are
and trying to support
them as settlers,
became platforms to have
workers rebound from job to job
and to leave the industries
and the companies
that we treat them badly,
to join other industries,
where they can find better
jobs, better opportunities.
It's a very different
kind of union.
It's not the same as the
industrial unions that
dominated the '40s economy, but
it wouldn't be the first time
that trade unions or
worker organizations
reinvent themselves to
account for a paradigm shift.
And so this is what we
should keep in mind.
So now, the reason--
so I said that my
book was written
to address an American
audience, but it particularly
addresses a segment
of that audience
and that is people working
in the US tech industry.
So entrepreneurs, tech
employees, tech investors,
and that's because I think
entrepreneurs can really
make a difference in discovering
the institutions that together
form the new safety net.
They're already at work doing
that because entrepreneurs
and tech companies
in general are
master of the art of solving
problems by using technology
and coming up with
innovative solutions.
And so I've made a
list-- so I'm constantly
updating the list of the many
startups that, in my view,
are working hard as we speak
at designing the new safety net
or discovering new solutions
that maybe at some point
could scale up and form
the new safety net.
So Lambda School
is a startup that
provide people with
the opportunity
to learn new skills, code.
And in exchange for a fraction
of their future income,
if they find a job.
So I position them here
between the financial system
and trade unions because
they're effectively
a financial institution.
They provide you with the
money to learn new skills
and you can pay them back later.
But they're also a bit
like a trade union,
because they have these very
strong community of people
learning to code together,
and they provide them
with the support they
need to find job,
and they have a clear interest
in you finding the best paying
job, because, again,
they're rewarded
with a fraction of your income.
So that's an example.
Another example is
Earnin, so it's a startup
that that's helping gig
workers and freelancers even
their income, and
employees be paid earlier
without having to wait for their
paycheck at the end of the week
or the end of the month.
Safety Wing is a startup that
provides insurance products
for digital nomads.
You have many startups
in the real estate space,
like Point or DV Homes.
You have Trupo, which
provides freelancers
with disability insurance.
You have Landed, which
is trying to help people
that they are not paid as
much as tech engineers,
like teachers, nurses, and so on
to find housing where they are
needed, et cetera, et cetera.
So Oscar is active
in the health space,
and there are many others.
So what I really
wanted to stress here
is that it's not only
about the government.
It's about all of us together.
We're all in that ultra
running race together,
and people that are
interested in tech
and that have already
succeeded in tech
should pay more attention to the
institutional part of the race,
and people that are involved
in policy and regulations
and government should
pay more attention
to what is happening
in the tech world,
and we should all
share that knowledge
to be able to run
that race together.
So I think it's important, and
I think it's urgent, by the way.
So my book was
published last year.
I think, today, it's even more
relevant for many reasons.
So we're moving forward to
the next presidential election
here in the US.
So there's already a lot
of conversations going on
about what the new policy should
be regarding the tech industry,
but how to upgrade the
social contract as well.
There's the rise of China.
And China, in many ways, is
inventing their own version
of the great safety net
2.0, because they're already
succeeding in the
digital economy,
and they really need
to provide their people
with stability and balance
and inclusiveness and so on.
There's Brexit.
There's populism all around
the world, et cetera.
So this is a picture
of Karl Polanyi, who
was an economic historian, known
for one book called "The Great
Transformation,"
which was published
in 1944, the last century.
And it's a book
that explains why
the shift to the '40s paradigm
early in the 20th century
led to the rise of fascism and
ultimately to World War II.
And it's because there was a
mismatch in many countries--
not the US, because the
US had the New Deal,
but in many other
countries, especially
in Europe, there was a
mismatch between what
the new economy was about, the
new risks to which people were
exposed, the new
problems that they
encounter in their daily life.
And there was a mismatch
with the institutions.
The institutions couldn't
provide people with the support
and stability that they
needed, and it all led
to a lot of pain,
suffering, anger,
and ultimately to
the rise of fascism.
So I think it's an
urgent discussion.
It's even more urgent today.
We're still in the
race to make the West--
what it used to be, that is,
the most advanced and the most
inclusive and the most
sustainable economy on Earth.
And I think we should--
remember that runner I
talked about at the beginning
of my talk--
I think what we should have in
mind is that it's a relay race.
It's a race where we have
to pass the baton many times
from people who know technology,
to people who know policy,
to people that are
ready to bridge
the gap between
those two worlds,
and my book, in many ways, is
a map for you to run that race,
so I invite you to have a look
at it, especially if you work
in tech as an employee, an
entrepreneur, or an investor,
and participate in that race
to help us win it together.
Thank you, and I have time for
questions if you have those.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for your talk.
My name is Dash.
So I am kind of leaning on
your question around settlers
and hunters.
I found it interesting that
you had technology companies
on the periphery, and
I was wondering if you
could speak more to that.
This is not an
egoistic question,
knowing that we're
here at Google.
It seems as if the
framework that you provided
has tech companies
at the center,
and center in the way of
empowering this kind of mesh
network of people.
And so that's definitely
a positive centering
for tech companies,
but we're also
seeing a negative centering
of tech companies.
[INAUDIBLE] and by that I
mean, yes, I can be networked.
But if I'm networked
in the sharing economy,
so I have a mobile phone, but
let's say I'm an Uber driver,
and I don't have--
yes, I have access to
information to switch jobs,
my current status in
life doesn't allow me
that kind of the exit
power to do that.
And so could you speak
a little bit more
to why you believe tech
companies are on the periphery
and maybe speak
a little bit more
nuanced in terms
of whether that's
a good thing or a bad thing,
should it be regulated,
should there be more
inroads between the kind
of the big tech companies
and new upstarts that
are trying to provide new
institutions to empower
more people?
NICOLAS COLIN: So what I
think to try and reformulate
what I said before is
the to be at the center
of this new economy or as close
to the center as possible,
you need to be entrepreneurial.
And being
entrepreneurial doesn't
mean being a tiny startup.
You can be entrepreneurial
in a large organization.
But being entrepreneurial
means that you
need to be ready to evolve
at the pace of the multitude
of networked individuals,
because, again, they're
constantly demanding better
products at a cheaper price.
They want to be served faster.
They want new features,
new bundles, new services,
et cetera.
And you can only afford
being close to them
if you you're able
to deliver that.
And so that's why the
economy is becoming
more and more entrepreneurial.
It's because most
large organizations
have a hard time serving
that multitude of demanding
networked individuals.
And so I have a
few cases in mind.
I think a company like Amazon
has done a great job scaling
up, while retaining
that capacity
to constantly innovate and to
question its business model
and to reinvent
itself, or expand
on to new markets
on a constant basis.
But the danger that large
organizations are exposed to
is that as they become larger,
they embark a lot of rigidity
and a lot of processes,
and they become complacent,
and they have difficulties to
change to expand, to explore
new territories, to learn
from their failures and so on.
And so I think that's the
challenge that every large tech
company has to tackle.
Do they want to remain
close to the center?
And for that, they need to
be more entrepreneurial.
Or if they're not
entrepreneurial enough,
they'll have the stability
and the security that
comes with many assets,
a strong balance sheet
and employing many
people, but they also
have the rigidity
that makes them
less relevant to the networked
individuals at the center.
And so I think that it's a good
thing that tech companies are
moving toward the center,
because at the center,
you basically submit to what
networked individuals want.
And so it's an entirely
different field of discussion,
like antitrust and
breaking up tech companies
and stuff like that.
But I think that the
networked individuals are now
strong enough to make sure that
the companies that sell them
act in their best interests.
And what is lacking is
only the institutions
to make it possible to provide
those people with stability,
security, and the
capacity to exit.
So you mentioned
those Uber drivers.
They're very close
to the center.
They're serving demanding
networked individuals.
They're also networked
themselves, as drivers,
as a company.
But they don't have the
safety net that provides them
with the stability and the
security and the support
that they need to make the
most of their current situation
and maybe rebound to
more rewarding positions
in the economy.
So this is why we need to
invent this new safety net.
It's simply to acknowledge
that the workforce has moved
from factories to urban
proximity services
and to provide those--
what's now the majority
of the workforce, that
is proximity service
workers, with the support
they need to become
the new middle class.
This is really
what's at stake here.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
regarding your book.
You began your book
with a personal anecdote
about when you were summoned
to court for an alleged
defamation against a leading
figure in the French taxi
industry.
Do instances like
this make you feel
that corporations are,
in fact, trying to put
a stop on those innovations?
NICOLAS COLIN: So I think--
well, yes, so there's
this anecdote,
which dates back
like six years ago,
when we founded
our firm in Paris.
At exactly the same
time, I wrote a blog post
that it put online criticizing
the CEO of the largest taxi
company in Paris because
he was introducing himself
in videos and interviews as--
well, the king of
innovation, if you will,
explaining how his taxi
company was innovating so much.
And what I wrote was
that in these interviews,
there was a deep
misunderstanding
of what innovation was about.
And if we relied on such
people to innovate, well,
we as a country, France
and Europe, in general,
will keep on lagging
behind the US and China.
And so he didn't like my blog
post and sued me in court,
and I was cleared later.
So that ended up OK.
But I introduced the
book with this anecdote
to try and share with
an American audience
what it's like to work
in tech in Europe.
Again, we don't have large tech
companies, like you have here.
But we have many startups
and many entrepreneurs
that realize that you can use
technology in an innovative way
and tackle problems that were
previously without a solution.
The problem is that
those entrepreneurs
have to battle against
powerful incumbents that
have everything to lose
with the economy changing.
They don't want those startups
entering their markets.
They don't want the value chain
to be redesigned according
to the needs of
networked individuals,
and they want regulations to
preserve the status quo as
opposed to lifting everyone up.
And so in Europe, we have to--
so you have that in the US.
But it's rather new.
It's called the backlash
against technology.
And tech companies have been
adapting the past two years
to that new context in
which they encounter
hostility from
basically everyone
from every part of the
political spectrum and so on.
This is new in the US,
but in Europe, it's
always been like that.
And so we who work
in tech in Europe,
we're used to battling
against a hostile environment
and to force
innovation, not only
by building great
startups that eventually
become great companies, but also
by sharing that narrative that
basically conveys the
message that startups are not
only about disruption
and destruction
and invading your
privacy and destroy jobs.
No, startups are the vanguard
of a new world, which
will reward all of us
with sustainability
and inclusiveness if we run
the two parts of the race.
The first part, again, that
is building great companies,
thriving companies.
And the part is parties
inventing new institutions.
AUDIENCE: Quick question
that I am constantly
struggling is how you see the
paradox of having institutions
that need to regulate the tech
industry that is moving so
fast, and you have institutions
that take a long time
to make a decision?
NICOLAS COLIN: It's
a good question,
because one of the features
of the '40s economy
was that it was a
very stable economy.
The only thing that was
unstable was consumer demand.
And the Great Safety
Net 1.0 was precisely
designed to provide
stability on consumer markets
to make it possible
for industrialists
to invest, to plan ahead and
to invest over the long term,
because they could,
thanks to the safety net,
and the stability
and the security
that it provided
to everyone, well,
they could count on sustained
consumer demand over the course
of years or decades.
Today-- so we had stability on
the production side or supply
side and instability
on the demand side.
And the economy
became more stable
because we corrected the
instability on the demand side
by building new institutions.
Today, the problem we have
is that there's instability
everywhere, like the
supply side is unstable,
because of increasing returns
to scale and network effects.
The demand side
is still unstable,
because people are
changing constantly
and want new products
and new services
and have new ideas constantly.
So how do you provide
stability in such an economy,
and how do you design
stable institutions
that pass the test of time?
I don't know actually.
This is why we really
need to run that race
and to enter the
discovery process.
And that goes through trials
and errors and errors and errors
before we finally
discover what works.
But what I am convinced
of is that you
can design institutions
for an unstable economy
with the goal of
providing stability.
So there's this concept by
Nassim Taleb called antifragile
And so antifragile
is not robust.
It's how do you survive in
a world that's constantly
changing in which you have to
reinvent yourself and rebound
and get back on your
feet throughout many ups
and downs and booms and busts.
And so it's an
interesting concept,
because this is really
what's at stake here.
We need to design
institutions that
will provide the
stability that's
missing in an economy dominated
by computing and networks.
And maybe those institutions--
so that one part of the book
discusses the
relevance of the state.
Like, the last time, stability
was provided by the state,
because the state was the
largest top down organizations
there was in a given country.
And so how could you
regulate the '40s economy
that was dominated by large
top down organizations
by inviting the largest
of those organizations
to enact the rules and to
watch over the various players.
Today, I'm not certain the
state is the player that's
able to deliver that.
Maybe the new
institutions will be
designed by a complex nexus
of different organizations,
acting like platforms, so
individuals themselves,
the new unions, tech
companies, and governments
all together will design
that process of upgrading
institutions to account
for the fast pace of change
in the economy.
It's not a top down approach.
In an economy dominated
by networked individuals,
you can't regulate that economy
with a top down approach.
And that's very much
the problem we have
on both sides of the Atlantic.
So in Europe, we
don't really get that.
So we're trying to do what
we did so well the last time.
That is, have the state
come up with regulations
imposed from the top down,
and it will provide balance.
Here in the US, you have
a better understanding
of what's going on,
but the government
is still far removed
from the tech industry
and doesn't interact
enough with that industry
to realize that maybe the top
down approaches at enacting
regulations don't work anymore.
So there's a lot of work to do.
And again, keep in mind
that that kind of work
is not only done
here in the West.
It's also done in China,
in Southeast Asia,
and maybe they'll come up
with new designs before we do,
and they'll invent their own
version of the safety net,
and they'll race ahead
towards economic development
while we in the West
will be lagging behind.
So that's very much
what's at stake here.
SPEAKER 1: All right, with that,
let's thank him one more time.
[APPLAUSE]